fehler für schritt hätte bestraft weil
man hätte einfach spaß
jeder will jetzt jeder auf dem platz
immer da und geht gern mal was ist
eigentlich eine art unsicher so ausdruck
wenn du die autos toxisch und was
täglich rasen löffel oder pause
derzeit komme dass in zehn jahren auf
der straße aber
persönlich 12 monate gratis konzert
wirklich
was ich strafe der vorteil gegenüber
tuner sind das alles nur rasen und pause
die willst geh morgen augusta und hauke
nina und lilith musste tuning szene
kennen
machen
sie sich
der effekt die auch zum impuls gespür
ihre community
was man sofort gesät durch fields werbe
und viel geld investiert waren der idee
am
gotthard steuer
wuchs rasant wie in der niederräder
meinem tollen autos mit einem auto und
auf schiffen mit dem hätten
wahrscheinlich leonetti draußen
[Musik]
persönlich
ein raser oder pose segen also
nase fahren zu schnell und völlig pose
verursachen unnötig lärm der stadt tuner
sind wiederum nur gern am aufschwung
aber die jetzt unterscheiden ist
schwierig
die stadt gab
dollar und wissenschaft
nicht und da ist irgendwie aber hier ist
somit kollegen traf und aus macht aber
spaß
mich fasziniert was die wasserreiche
durchaus das auto personalisieren und
dann nach einer art von sich aus druck
von 24 tag ein duopol
auffälliger als andere ist aber trotzdem
und wege der säge ist sogar schon mal
vor der polizei beschlagnahmt worden
dank hat bo pjsc usa auflösen
meine hobbys verstanden werde das auto
ja der tag war der verdacht dass
motorleistung und darf gasag bearbeiten
und zwar so motorische original und
abgas al akhbar bald dass ich in jedes
buch da haben sich die new yorker unter
und dass man ihn gemacht war das wo sich
handelt und ja sehr internet würde
fröbel nähe und einfach alles
was ich denke
schon dass ich nicht viel machen und der
eltern müssen sich viele den trainings
einfach mal drei autos
[Musik]
doch während nadal ist cool blieben
findet alle verbauen nur legal italien
ihren autos ps und lautstärke sind
wichtige der community und
verbesserter aerodynamik
während meiner recherche hatte am anfang
große skepsis fotocommunity gespürt
dieses risiko finster meistens einmal
eine antwort direkt auf mich noch nie
ersetzen aber mit der cdu gesprochen
dass sie ihre reportage zu dem thema
machen und den sich viele
jetzt zum beispiel wie immer ihr als die
heutige gesellschaft wird leider zu oft
schubladisiert es ist so dass es ab und
somit trouble geht mit ludwig von der
konzern ist genauso wie jedem anderen
bereich was das auch immer idioten gibt
was dieser schritt ist interessant der
tuner oder auto und josef wilp ärger und
wird sich so begrüße ohne andere helfer
oder des autors verlierer hosen sind
tabu kayani kennt und man mehr sie klare
differenzierung
abermals ein interessantes für die
medien geht es doch kai differenzierung
und alle werden im licher top gehört
spricht juni werden grundsätzlich
informiert
vor der kamera wenn da wo die wenig
stäube der träger zu große stand falsch
dargestellt werden in den medien
china bilder sammeln will eben lange
wenn sich nie report wäre öffentlich
können sich das mit der schubladisierung
auch nicht viel besser ich treffe ihn
bis ich da ein bisschen baby das in dem
auto bleibt es in die liga schafft also
ich bin
bezieht raumfrachter ich bin ich bin
drauf
und
fertig wird soll bis nicht also bis
jetzt mal der motor ist also wer
zwischen
beispiel schafft dass du dir so also ob
das jetzt ist der sanitär ich so mache
den sport
und ich lerne schuber schlägerprozess
sowie saftigen der verlust der prozess
dass noch ein wirklich als
warenlager nach abschluss der stadt und
wirklich
spaß für mich
selber mit seinem kollegen fahrer von
bülach it garagen startup week
naja was rund 9
also ich sehe nicht dass man in der hand
das ist auch so dass das
[Musik]
ganze ein teil von mir all die vr bank
sitzen
ass vorteil wie übrigens auch immer
wieder gehört alte autos sind liest sie
erklärend mir aber dass autos fortune er
nicht liest sind weil sie so
festgeschrieben dass wir kein
leasing-vertrag zu holen
neben braucht wurde gino schafft teterow
nun eigene garage september wie verdient
mit services an autos aus der region und
natürlich
unter dem wird diskutiert an einer
autofirma kolleg
frontlippe
[Applaus]
stofftiere konnte
die tal sind streng reglementiert und
nun vom straßenverkehrsamt abgesegnet
werden einige sparen bietet dreckig und
genau das gibt probleme oder
polizeikontrollen also ehrlich sagt
yannick gruner oder fotos aber dieselbe
bedeutet viel mehr als bis zu ende
geschrieben und da gibt es beim
klassiker also sicher klassisch
oder pop suite verwaltet sich fort also
folie täter bis zu andere
bauteile wie zum beispiel dann diffusor
von axa von clipper wo kann der
erwartete andere fahrerinnen
das ist show idee und die vorzüge
meistermann dass ihr das auto typisch
ersten autos wie man im radsport bessere
vorgenommen ich will den schwerpunkt im
auto töffli zweitens sind die
verarbeitung und meistens vor der
vorstellung besser für performance ford
besser als unter umständen ist bequemer
je nachdem wie man es dann abstimmt und
externe ruf wird sich von anderen
größtenteils hauptsächlich frauen sind
klar an der nähe zum wahnsinnig viel
loser oder frauen die meisten autos von
miriam hand sind aber schon
handtasche und dass gott hauptsache nach
der pflege zuständige vorstand
der größte teil bessere
das ist ja etwas lustiger einfach
weitermachen ist schon die umstände die
für die nahtlose rohre in originalem
ever done to install other words aber
dafür lud und dann nur den auspuff
runter farbe werden automatisch zwischen
1 und 5 30 franken
genau der ton reckt lied es gibt sogar
mäßiger aus der stadt zürich zu der
lärmbelästigung wo belegt der verkehr
ist stück lichter am wochenende der big
verursacht von uid voghera ihrem motor
current mit autos gesehen wie das
darüber einig sind es so der ju bord zum
beispiel
es geht relativ groß dass autos hier
geht es mal was kostet was kostet das
herz schädigen das im gestärkt
investition erst jetzt nochmal genau
dann in mir richtig sauber zählt solche
kreuzer vor
aber schon nach wenigen
vorstößen dachte teilnehmer zu lassen
kann
ohne zu
verdanken na ich hoffe ja sogar das
komplette auto hat die polizei
praktisch
da muss man auch ständig vorhalten und
alt als legaler das mal kein problem
juli präsentiert für mich die rüd wo
marcus sorg der betrugs muss verleiteten
tegel und pflege also ich muss mir gäbe
das motto wo war das schön ist das für
sie passt das auch für sie stimmt
für mich lieb war
das
ist mit neun wagen er musste kurz darauf
ist auch für mich das auch passe ich
mache das für mich schön ist und für die
andere und das für mich der
hauptunterschied so der autor pose für
die evo einfach weiterstadt oderbruch
damit
läuft das
macht für mich
und so ist das ja vor
silber jahr für jahr
neu mit dem bis jetzt
zwei büro
aufgefordert und
sie verbringen die ihre samtiger wird
übrigens lady gaga stadt in der stadt
browser sind er rät
meine für was will muss schnell sehr
dynamische auto haben es nicht weit
die narrischen mechatroniker erich
scheffer sondern der crew also nach
verein für autoliebhaber und sie
fachsimpeln selber sprechen sie
krawatten zu
und die scheint recht zu machen glaubt
dass im blick hey
was ist das da bitte
also schaut auf den vater aber
verschiedene grinds ist ja auch das gar
nicht in betrieb sehen aber es gibt aus
konz - ford macht nicht die und aber ist
mit einer schikane ab das fahrrad hat
sie organisiert und fahren deshalb auch
vorne dran und geben vor wut über drei
pässe flüela grimm sind und zustand
treffpunkt mit der anderen art dorf
kanton uri zum hobby nach es ist schön
in der stadt gehen wo man vor da sind
wir aber näher bringen
die cellulite sie erstellt und so kann
auch der dax darunter das
älteste buch der ausfallzeit mit der
ganzen
schwierige zeit nämlich über 200
mitglieder in der schweiz und über 100
die muss land
ja
ja so komische stimmung am meisten lust
zum beispiel im rahmen des
projekts gehört weiß ich oft
dort wo es
ja
der crew will in ortsnähe vater
wenigstens etwas lose stärke betrifft
sie werfen sogar mitglieder aus den usa
wo sich nicht an die regel halten
sie fahren dahin komplett mode und hohem
gang
und so den sportmodus
schön
das ist ein unterschied schon
was ich denn das geile da zum besten
ich habe auch so spielt dort technischen
landschaft es sind
speziell
der zeitpunkt und ort und hat
bis man eine kohlfahrt noch an den fluss
fiel plötzlich wie heißt mit dem
fahrzeug reisende straße es ist schön
diese fracht durch den 17 ich verachte
kraft und das
nicht möglich
meistens gilt 80 auf der bachstraße vom
dach bis zu 100 km/h
noch gar nicht
alle forderungen durchsetzen
als raser gilt november viel zu schnell
fahren sondern auch wenn man extra
völlig fahrt zum beispiel mit
straßenrennen macher oder mit sehr
gefährlich überholt und dann ist es weg
sofort meine recherche bin ich auf
menschen gestoßen wo deshalb keineswegs
mir scheint es ist mehr als ein
einzelfall zum ali mit dem vorteil dass
weniger schwierig
so
übelkeit level also was ich von eins bis
zehn ist so falsch nicht schlecht aber
mehr auch nicht schlecht
das wird neues material von instagram
produziert bildmaterial für ihre zum
teil musiker voll ins tal schon sehr
sehr wichtige plattform für ist also ich
danke für 14 jährigen zu tagesaktionen
neue und es scheint jeder gegenüber
dienste
plattform oder ganz bewusst um
stattfindet
[Musik]
überholt wird aber er habe nie wirklich
unsicher gefühlt - aber definitiv
pfleger wenn ich so überholt über ändern
weiß ich dass ich das auch so
es gibt
wo sind mein gesperrt ja ich verstehe ja
dass man sie für jene b c d
susanne vitalis schloss zusammen es geht
auch ganz andere andere blöd ist auch
wann der mut machen also genauso
unsicher sind es gibt männer vaters
gefordert von - genauso wie wir sie von
der doppelspurigen straße vom fc
metz so viel hängt ab kennt wird juni
gewählten mit raserei einen topf
geworfen und die muss ehrlich sagen als
außenstehender könnte das überhaupt mit
unterscheiden wie andere mitglieder foto
crew sind sich bewusst dass das
schwierig ist wie schon andere
vorhergesagt mal genau es war ein toller
fahrer damit jetzt anständig
video tore vater will ich das meistens
tracht oder
auto ja das ist so eine oder du musst du
einen abstand wird dagegen wehren sie
sich jetzt auf social media mit dem
hashtag safetypay schon
jetzt sowohl
politische oder einfach
einfach nur 5 max mache das nicht alle
so sind aber wenn es mal ein flugzeug
an ein anderes buch da aber dass wegen
dieser diskussionen 1500 m zweiter gang
machen
macht spaß ist also
das töne zu nicht blöd aber für mich als
journalist
ich komme eine immer der verlust daßlitz
heilige darstellen anders als das sind
dieselben debattieren ob das ihnen
gegenüber unfair ich will also zahlen
wirklich schon ganzen tag mit ihnen
verbracht hast und alles was sie
erzählen auch wenn man nichts kamera
nach was da eigentlich zudem wo sie auch
ihre interviews abend also
ich glaub sie
[Musik]
[Applaus]
was jetzt noch ist im dreck hört an der
china selber
darüber reden petra behle
[Musik]
in cazis amt juni-session
toyota jason
kann direkten import aus japan meines
wissens gibt es in der schweiz noch fünf
stück von der migros ist ja schwieriger
für mich der geschichte dass man mit
kaviza jede konzern will
also ich hätte sehr gern transparenz ich
denke ich sprich auch jeder jede legte
bis wir ich sage klar jeder wo ist jeder
auf dem platz kürze motor und gern
einmal gas es gibt aber durch zwei späte
die einte die katze nicht wo das gas
geben es gibt andere nehmen rücksicht
das sind emotionen wo man ja gern hätte
wüsste wie man sich benimmt die andere
nötig haben
immer alle in einen topf werfe als pose
und trance beschrieben das ist falsch
aber was sich auf sich ich zum ali in
der heilige topwerfer und als heiliger
abstempeln will das sind sicher auch
nicht es geht lütow schnellfahrens lud
fahren und einen falschen ort
und da lief oder einer
ihrer lust auf das glaube ich schon was
nimmst du mich und wie einfach die
vorurteile gegenüber tuner und juni